listen Disney princesses we've got some
questions for you gals we really want to
know what you make of the changes that
your franchise has gone through over the
years we're looking at you Snow White
Cinderella and Aurora do you wish you
were modern-day princesses so you didn't
have to wait around for a man to save
you are you envious of Elsa Moana and
Merida who didn't wish their time
waiting around for true love's kiss
Disney's sure is switching things up
when it comes to creating women that
girls can look up to as role models
Disney Princesses have come a super long
way they're independent ladies who don't
need men to save them Disney's changed
their motivations too it's not just
about finding a husband anymore if you
wear a dress and you have an animal
sidekick your princess
[Music]
keep watching to the end to discover
which princesses journey represents the
changes that have taken place over the
entire franchise to see just how far
Disney princesses have come we need to
look at the earliest movies Snow White
Cinderella and Aurora are a world away
from the modern era princesses these
three original princesses from the
Golden Age era have lots of things in
common their skills were pretty much
restricted to housework
they were subservient and helpless their
dreams centered on finding love and
getting married they all had female
villains they couldn't fight off
themselves these damsels in distress
needed to be protected by a man they
waited around for a prince to come and
save them these movies were made in the
1930s and 1950s but as time went on
Disney realize that girls needed
different role models they needed strong
independent women to look up to changes
came with the Renaissance era of
princesses this started in 1989 with
Ariel and continued with Belle Desmond
Pocahontas and Mulan throughout the 90s
these princesses started become more
varied and independent they had more
impact and power but there was still a
love story at the center of their tales
sure Ariel's actions triggered the
events of her movie you'll remain human
permanently but her motivations became
focused on marrying Erik Jasmine wanted
freedom from her father but her story
sent it on her relationship with Aladdin
Belle didn't conform to society's
expectations however she was all tied up
with Beast of course I came back
Pocahontas stopped a war but her tail
was tangled up in a love triangle
Mulan fought in the army however her
happy endings still showed a man in the
picture it would take a while for Disney
to make big leaps with the way female
protagonists were being presented the
Disney revival era which began with the
princess in the frog in 2009 rang the
changes Tiana is a more relatable
character for a modern-day audience
she works for a living in fact she's the
only Disney princess who has an actual
job but there was still a love story
pushing events on you just kissed
yourself a princess the same goes for
tangled in 2010
Rapunzel needed Flynn to save her from
her Tower unlike the Golden Age
princess's house
for Rapunzel and Flynn ended up with a
more equal relationship they saved each
other but Disney still hadn't broken
free from the love story element then
that all changed in 2012 the release the
brave Harold a major breakthrough in the
Disney Princess franchise this Pixar
produced movie gave audiences and overt
heroine with Meredith her actions drive
the story
she's explicitly uninterested in
marriage and rejects this as a primary
motivator she knows that finding
romantic love isn't the only way to be
happy or to keep her community together
she saved the day without the help of a
man being a princess became different
with this movie with the move away from
romantic love towards the importance of
family love the Disney Princesses
motivations had well and truly changed
Disney continued with this new kind of
princess heroine with frozen in 2013 no
I'm just trying to protect you Elsa has
no love interest and is interesting and
active in her own right
the female characters in this movie
support each other and save their
community together through the strength
of their sisterly love interestingly
Elsa sheds light on the whole franchise
she tells Anna you can't marry a man you
just met and she could well be talking
to those Golden Age princesses - who all
married men they'd only just met Anna
had a similar view to her predecessors
she tells Elsa that you can marry a man
you've just met if it's true love
Elsa counters by asking Anna Anna what
do you know about true love and she's
got a point let's remember that Snow
White was only 14 in her film let that
fact sink in these early princesses
didn't exactly have much life experience
and were all marrying the first man they
ever really met the same goes for the
Renaissance princesses we can view
honest journey as representative of how
Disney change that princesses over the
years she goes from being focused on
waiting for a man to show up and marry
her to being a total heroine saving her
sister in 2016
Disney went one step further with Moana
this movie totally lacked any romantic
themes with Moana were given another
heroine who's making things happen she's
strong and capable has agency and is
doing the saving all on her own so what
do the Disney Princesses themselves
think about all this
we got a fascinating insight in the 2018
movie Ralph breaks the Internet when the
princesses are deciding whether
vanellope is a princess too
Rapunzel says to her do people assume
all your problems got solved because a
big strong man showed up that pretty
much sums up what the princess is used
to stand for and we're so glad Disney is
changing that message which Disney
princess is your favorite tell us in the
comments make sure to LIKE and subscribe
to the things for more videos like this
one thanks for watching we'll catch you
later
[Music]